a vaginal yeast infection is a common
condition where too much yeast grows in
a woman's vagina other names for it are
Volvo vaginal candidasis and candida
Volvo vaginitis yeast is a type of
fungus which is a plant-like organism
the type of yeast that usually causes
the infection is called Candida
Albans your vagina is the passage from
the uterus to the outside of your
body the surface inside your vagina
normally contains small amounts of this
yeast which usually doesn't cause any
problems other germs such as the healthy
bacterium lactobacillus also live in the
vagina with candida they keep each other
in
Balance sometimes conditions change in
the vagina that make the yeast grow out
of
control when this happens yeast cells
invade the lining of your vagina called
mucosal
epithelium as the yeast grows and
damages your cells it causes immune
cells to enter the
tissue this inflames and damages the
tissue as your immune cells try to clear
the
infection unfortunately ye cells can
avoid immune destruction by killing
immune
cells or ye cells May grow too large for
immune cells to destroy them this allows
the yeast to grow and spread forming a
layer called a bofilm in your
vagina it's not always clear why a
person gets a yeast
infection but you're more likely to get
a yeast infection if you are pregnant
have
diabetes wash the inside of your vagina
also known as
douching have a weakened immune system
take birth control pills or have taken
antibiotics or steroid
drugs the most common symptom of a yeast
infection is an extreme itchy feeling in
your vagina and your vulva which is the
area around the entrance to your
vagina other symptoms may include
redness burning and swelling in your
vagina or vulva pain during urination or
sex and a thick white odorless discharge
from your
vagina you you can treat a vaginal yeast
infection with antifungal medicines
these medicines may be creams or
suppositories that you apply in your
vagina or they may be pills you take by
mouth it's important to use an
antifungal medication for as long as the
directions tell you to don't stop using
them early even if your symptoms go
away some of the ways you can help
prevent a vaginal yeast infection
include only washing your vulva not
inside your vagina and not using doues
or hygiene sprays keeping the genital
area clean and dry not wearing tight
underwear or pants wearing underwear
with a cotton crotch always wiping front
to back after using the toilet cleaning
your vva after sex and keeping your
blood sugar under control if you have
diabetes also take antibiotics for other
infections only as prescribed
antibiotics May kill healthy bacteria
that keep yeast in check which can lead
to a yeast
infection to find out more about vaginal
yeast infections talk to your Healthcare
practitioner